thank you
uh good morning everybody and welcome to
this latest meeting of the trafford
covered 19 public engagement board
um which has come at a time when um
we seem to be going uh having made steps
forward
since making some steps backwards so
this is quite an important meeting this
morning
i have apologies this morning from
caroline hemingway joanne gibson thomas
maloney
michelle hill sarah sarah lad radcliffe
shaun denellen councillor chilton
councillor canola
helen grant and we just said gila
burgess allen as well
um and can i just start by thanking my
colleague councillor slater
for sharing in my absence on the last
meeting on the second of june
are there any other apologies at all
no right are there um any decorations of
interest in any items on the agenda
judith
uh just to say mike that um i've got to
leave the meeting earlier because
uh somebody's uh arranging another
meeting for me
which i apologize for thank you for
letting me know judith burton thanks for
attendance this morning
uh moving on then to the minutes of the
meeting of the 2nd of june can i please
take them as read
and can we approve them as an accurate
record of that meeting
thank you uh we'll move on swiftly then
too
i think eleanor you've got three items
update on the current covert 19
situation national announcements
regarding code restrictions
and our response to the proposed
additional support interventions which
have been
obviously the plan has been circulated
and also the booklets which i think are
excellent
so what i'll do is if we want to combine
all three and let you talk through
and then invite questions at the end is
that okay
you're on you telling her ellen you're
on mute
is that better yeah sorry um
so what i thought i'd do was um if i
just give a quick run through where
we're up to with the current situation
and the national announcements and then
i'll ask ben to talk us through the plan
so that we have some different voices
which will be
i'm sure people will be pleased so um
the national situation well the local
situation at the moment is across
greater manchester we continue to see
our rates rising and well the relatively
good news is that
our rates in trafford are now the third
lowest in greater manchester
we're still the 17th highest in england
so and all 10 of the greater manchester
boroughs are now in the top 20 in
england so i think that just gives you
a little bit of um of the context that
we're working in at the moment
um bolton where we saw the rates rising
most quickly
their rate they're now the third highest
so their rates are slowly coming down
um and they've been overtaken by other
boroughs and what we've seen
in previous times as we've entered peaks
has been that our rates go up very much
more quickly than they come down
and i just think we need to really bear
that in mind we're also
um in terms of our older population
um our rates in that group are so we're
at 200
100 overall um in our whole population
but for our older people the rates are
um about 45 per hundred thousand so
substantially lower but still a worrying
rate
particularly when you think of the level
of
vaccination within that population the
good news is the vaccination does seem
to be holding and
we're hoping that that will remain
although hospitalizations are now rising
so i really do want to urge everybody
that this is the point we need to
continue taking
this extremely seriously and certainly
from a public health view
point of view um i think we're very re
we're very pleased
that the restrictions have not been
raised
and that we have a little bit more time
to get on top of it because over the
next four weeks if we can get our
vaccination rates up
and also do everything we can around the
contact tracing of
our current cases and make sure people
are self-isolating
and i'd really call for everybody's
support in this
um because we know that people
do much better contact racing on their
own of their own contacts of their
friends and family
if you are positive please go for a test
tell your friends tell anyone you've
seen
make sure they self-isolate too and
we've seen so many examples of really
getting on top of quite nasty outbreaks
very quickly
because of the actions that our local
population have taken
and people behaving an incredibly
responsible manner
and that's across the age range um rates
at the moment are highest
in our younger age groups so um in
particular in our 17 to 21 year olds
but actually all of the under under 40s
rates are high
they sort of and our secondary school
rates are going up a bit as well at the
moment
um we've got cases across the whole of
the borough and what we're seeing at the
moment
actually is quite interestingly that
we're seeing a bit more of a grouping
than we had
so we are seeing at the i think our
lowest ward
has rates of over 130 per hundred
thousand and our highest
ward has rates just over 300 per hundred
thousand
but most you know a lot of grouping
really
um and and a big spread so we've got
high rates
in hail central embolden in altering
them
in clifford in longford in davey hume
east
in stratford so a real a real
spread of disease i'm afraid across the
whole of the borough
um i think at the moment then the main
messages i'd be saying is that
businesses as well have a massive role
in reducing risk
and we all have a role to play in the
workforce in making sure
even if we've been vaccinated even if we
have both vaccines
please do take that extra care at the
moment because
even though everyone's vaccinated
there's or even if you are vaccinated
and everybody you you
you know it's unlikely that everybody
you mix with will be vaccinated
so we just need to try and take
additional care at the moment so that it
doesn't get into our most vulnerable
populations
and for our younger age groups um you
know while the fit
well the risk of death is obviously much
much lower
um long coverage does produce you know
is a significant risk to that age group
and when you you know any of these
post-viral symptoms syndromes can be
very very nasty
and have a massive impact on people's
lives so i would really urge people to
be extremely cautious at the moment
avoid indoor noisy crowded places
stay outdoors wherever you can and still
absolutely
you know while it's really good to go
out get out enjoy the sunshine do try
and make sure that you don't
don't mix with too many people and and
if you like keep an
eye keep a track on how many people
you're seeing the number of people we
mix with is always much more than the
number we think it is
um and i think we need to you know just
try and keep that little
that little mental tally going of who
would i have to tell if i if i felt ill
and if i tested positive
um so in terms of the national uh
announcement obviously and i and i
completely understand that it probably
is only people in public health who are
pleased to have the restrictions
continuing and i don't expect anyone
else
to share um that with me and on a
personal level
a non-professional level obviously i'm
i'm as disappointed as anyone else
um but i do think that this is gives us
an opportunity to get on
to allow the vaccinations to start
working and to get on top of things so
that we can have
a much better summer and autumn and
winter
going forward um
we um so it in terms of the net the
other thing as well as the national
announcement on monday
about the restrictions continuing till
the 19th of july
or and we hope that they will be lifted
then um
we also had an announcement for greater
manchester on monday that we were going
to be an
enhanced response area and the
government issued a plan
with 10 points on it that we have with
that we've been um
that has been uh suggested that we could
work on
or that we would be wanting needing
additional support to deliver
um i'm going to ask ben in a minute to
talk us through our response
to that plan the two elements that were
the element that we particularly wanted
additional support with from for greater
manchester
and for trafford specifically was
additional supplies of vaccination
but unfortunately we haven't been able
to be given any additional supplies
however
the national program has now opened
up bookings to everybody over 18 and on
tuesday last week i think a million
people nationally
of that when it was open to the 25 to 29
year olds a million people booked on one
day
so we know that there's massive demand
in that population
so i'm really delighted that it's
opening up to the over 18s what we will
be doing locally
is trying to make sure that we reduce
that deprivation gap that we continue to
see
in uptake of vaccination because we we
continue to have our most
poorer populations who often at higher
risk of covid either because of
underlying health conditions or because
of face-to-face work
for and because of potentially living in
overcrowded accommodation and so on
those po that population we are really
um we will be focusing
our attention on making sure that we
make it as easy as possible for that
everybody in that group to get
vaccinated and to have their second dose
so that's one of the major pieces of
work that we'll be undertaking
but i'm going to ask ben now to talk us
through
the presentation and our response to um
the enhanced i think we're calling it an
enhanced response plan it changed name
about seven times last week
um but i think for us we'll call it our
enhanced response plan
and there's quite a lot of actions for
people i think in this group
for councillors for people from the vcsc
sector we really do need your support
and your help
and your views on this plan to make sure
that we can implement it effectively
so um your feedback on this would be
very very gratefully received um
it's a plan that we've put together and
obviously
if people have better ideas and want to
give more contributions to it
and ex you know think about how we could
deliver it better we are
always very very open to having our plan
improved
so ben can i hand over to you yes
absolutely let me just go and bring it
up on the screen
and can you let me know if you can see
that
i'm saying that's fantastic so um we'll
just go through a quick summary
talk through that action plan um and
then give an idea about what activity
we've done so far and what activity that
we've got coming up
so as eleanor mentioned this plan is a
response to the fact that we've seen
a um a rising cases um
and this plan has come from the um
nationally
key areas involved in it are around
vaccination uptake
schools workplace engagement i think
it's communications
and community engagement so because that
work is required across a number of
different areas including testing
vaccinations contact tracing and
community business engagement
because of that there's a need for a
really strong vcsc volatile contribution
to make sure that we maximize that
impact and effectiveness and as
restrictions are lifted
the demands on services such as
regulatory services is absolutely going
to increase
as to the demands of volunteer time now
connected to that our volunteer
coordinator is now in place which is
fantastic news
um although it is worth emphasizing here
that the pace of work means that
recruiting volunteers for
time-specific work can be a challenge
because of how quickly things are moving
basically
when it comes to getting enough people
in place we we know that it's something
that we need to work on
um given how quickly things are moving
so going on to the ten point plan as you
say against each of those areas we've
gone and put a number of different um
actions in place
so number one is around the potential
request
for more military support so as part of
that we're scoping out with other
brewers in
um greater manchester how we could
potentially use that support going
forward
um number two is around supervised
in-school testing
so we split that into two different
areas for primary schools um
we will look to test parents and carers
if we see a significant increase in
cases
or an outbreak in school that hasn't
seen an outbreak before
we also have the potential to use tester
release for contacts for higher age
groups
so that will essentially mean that if we
um have
a um a case and an entire bubble that
would normally go off
we could go and test that bubble every
single day and as long as they tested
negative they could continue to
participate in school for
secondary schools obviously the routine
expectation is to continue that two
weekly um electro flow home tests um
in a small outbreak again we could
consider the use of test
release and in a larger outbreak or
where community rates are
really high okay and we can look at
using whole school
one or flatter flow testing um and would
use our own testing team as part of that
number three is around wastewater
testing sample sequencing
so all we're going to do there is
continue to review the data on that and
use that to inform
where we need to put our focus towards
number four and there's a lot of access
to
number four is around our specialist
communications so
um already um our communications team i
mean
clinton ellie who's on the call today
has produced two booklets um
one for members of the public and one
for businesses
um that just really kind of highlight
those key public health messages
and i think we've got images that we can
go and share with you on that later on
um this week we have an advertising ban
um that is um going around the border
again trying to really emphasize those
key messages that are going to be
focused on
hours of low of vaccine uptake busy
roads busy shopping areas
and pick up and drop off times at
schools and again i think we have some
images to show later on
um and they look really good i've seen a
few already and it's i think it really
does kind of get across the key messages
we're trying to push
um as well as this the department of
health and social get ads um that have
already involved now
and are going to focus on concern and
really trying to
um personally need to be vigilant and in
traffic at the moment
other comms areas around street teams so
this is a
national community engagement team um
that will be in place in the area that
we choose um
likes to be towards the end of june or
the start of july
um our self-isolation offer starts this
week which we're really happy about
so footing was provided for targeted
areas so trafford
we're going to be focusing this on the
m15 and 16 postcodes
and essentially how that's going to work
is it's looking to provide additional
support for people
to self-isolate because we know that is
a big big challenge for a number of
people
um if they go and test positive and as
well as this finally on our community
engagement work
um their our community agent team will
be looking to do additional work primary
schools
um they're currently supporting a
self-isolation guidance post or
competition in schools
um and continuing the ongoing messaging
around that kind of key network so
mosques
mini champions like community hooked and
also looking at what work
and they can do over the summer holidays
so moving on number five which is
our drive to increase vaccination uptake
so we have uh kind of key targets in
place so that's initially for cohorts
one to nine
in every area to initially get to a 85
percent and be
90 uptake in the next few weeks and then
following that
cohorts 10 to 12 to get 85 and 90 uptake
by the end
of july um we'll be looking to work with
our kind of key stakeholders
and understand what the kind of key
focuses should be in order to make sure
that we hit those targets
um and then also making sure that we
utilize as best as possible our
community engagement
um and that will include working closely
with manchester on that kind of m15 m16
border as well number six is around
additional control measures in education
so already a number of weeks ago
um we asked for for secondary schools
for school pupils and staff to
restart wearing face coverings in
communal areas
number seven is around compliance and
enforcement so officers are continuing
to work with the police and health and
safety executive
to make sure that they coordinate
intelligence and enforcement activities
across the borough
number eight is uh around a vaccine
champion so currently we kind of scoping
out what that one expectations would be
but it's probably worth emphasizing here
that we're already working obviously
really closely with our vcsc partners
um many of which have done a fantastic
job of trying to push an increased
vaccination uptake
so i think we've already done quite a
large amount of work around that element
anyway
number nine is around spot check so like
this is our offices from our regulatory
services team continuing to undertake
the checks and businesses to make sure
they operate in that cover-secure manner
manner
and that will come about as a result of
maybe complaint or maybe
an increase in cases and the team will
obviously undertake
kind of a program of proactive visits as
well as reactive visits
um in line with local intelligence
finally then around government
guidance um so they'll continue to push
those key messages
around minimizing mixing when you do mix
fixing outdoors
and obviously really really encouraging
people to go take those lots of flow
tests twice a week
and obviously with given that the
european championships on at the moment
um kind of really pushing that key
message to hospitality about being
oversecure
and that message to residents of being
safe when they're in those hospitality
settings so just to kind of give you an
example of how we've kind of you know
started to put some of this into action
already and then talk about some stuff
that we've got coming up
um over the last two weeks we've done um
engagement and pcr testing for parents
and carers in two primary schools
where we did um 261 tests and engaged
with over 200 people
we're also doing a door knocking
exercise um in
north trafford with our community
engagement team and our testing team
where we spoke to 356 houses and
completed 93 tests
we've done outbreak testing for a
business instructor recently where we've
done over 200 tests at the town hall
and we've handed out over 500 lots of
flow home testing kits to
a pencil carrier in a primary school
recently
we've also had some mobile test units at
the traffic center
where we handed out over 100 kits we've
also provided them with electrical flow
testing kits as well
um and that's obviously including the
vaccination clinics and ongoing
engagement support that's happened
so coming up then um we've got whole
school watch flow testing at two
secondary schools and traffic this week
we're also going to be
uh testing parents and carers at a prime
school as well that should be happening
on thursday
um as mentioned before we've got the
advertising ban um going around the
borough of really kind of pushing those
key public health messages and we've got
the launch of the self-isolation offer
we're continuing to promote vaccination
clinics and coordination of volunteers
and as mentioned those ongoing checks of
businesses especially in light of the
euros
finally that targeted support the key
groups including the salem seekers
refugees and homeless people
so there is such a large amount of work
that's occurred already and
much much more work planned um so we're
really trying to push as much as
possible given those rising rates
and that's everything on the ten point
plan unless anyone has any questions so
yeah could have you got the ability ben
to bring up the uh
two booklets which we could just show um
and then we can go into questions
is that have you got those can you do
that
let me just go in get this up give me
one second
the joys of technology thank you
so again can you let me know in a second
if you can see my screen
can fantastic i'll just slowly
scroll down here
so again this is all thanks to um our
communications leader lee cardi who's
doing a fantastic job pulling all this
together
and then whilst you look at that i'll
just go on quickly
bring up the second one
so again just really trying to push
those those key messages
um around testing given self-isolation
um and around vaccinating
and i think in the um in the one for the
families we're particularly i'm
stressing the support that
can be given to self-isolation because
we know how difficult that is for many
people
and i think also people's definitions of
household
um is often varied you know that so
we're really trying to make sure that
people understand that that's
the people who actually live in your
house rather than extended family
or friends that you're very close to and
so on that we really are trying to get
it
get support people to be able to um to
manage
uh with with no you know absolutely
minimize any social mixing
and i think people you know often people
feel oh well children playing out and so
on but of course that's also
also a risk so it's it's it is very
difficult especially
obviously especially difficult for any
family who doesn't have
good access to to a garden um
at the moment uh try it with
and and this is something i think we'll
be will be needing to push across the
whole of the summer holidays as well
the importance of um if you are
if you are a if you are a case or if
there's cases in the family
really trying to make sure people do
limit that contact with other people
can i ask the self-isolation package
clearly
going back some time ago that it was a
500 pound
offer are we are we offering the same
again
this time so there are two there are two
packages so there's the 500 pound offer
that's open to anyone who's on a low
income and all the criteria for that are
on the
council website so um we can um people
all the information is on the council
website we also have a more intensive
support package
which i think we've got um either kate
or
laura cursey on the call later who can
talk through that
more intensive package which is targeted
at people in the
m16 area because we've got limited
funding for this each area of greater
manchester
has identified one one area um
of a limited number of people who would
be that we're targeted
that we're able to offer additional
support now that may be financial it may
be support with shopping it may be
support with um dog walking all sorts of
other things
so that people can be supported to do
that self-isolation
so that's a pilot um scheme is part of a
research evaluation program that's going
on across greater manchester so
so we are we have part of the borough
covered by that
um as part of research and evaluation
exercise
thank you um i invite questions then can
i ask if you could possibly use the
raised hand
so i can catch everybody or council the
new cross you've indicated straight away
anyway so off you go thank you very much
chair
um you've just answered one of my
questions which was on the
self-isolation offer right you mentioned
it was focused on it
it's restricted too uh i would have
loved it to be available
widely but okay it is what it is um of
the 10
uh point plan much is made of tests
there there's plenty of things on test
there's nothing at all on trace not
gonna mention um and and
looking at the graphics of these uh two
brochures i notice it uses the
traditional um
coveted symptoms of uh cough contingency
coughing
and loss of smell um it the
i'm hearing reports that the delta
variant has slightly different
um symptom sets and
i don't want to blur a message but that
could be something we might need to
consider
so that's where um so um kirsty's
joining the call in a bit to talk more
about the self-isolation pathway so i'll
leave that until later on the agenda on
the symptoms we are getting more reports
of sore throat runny nose and headache
being symptoms that seem to be
associated with the delta variant
i think at the moment what we would
encourage people to do is if you have
symptoms that make you think you might
have covered
go and do a pcr test don't just do a
lateral flow
because the lateral flow can come back
negative even
it's more likely to give you a false
negative than the pcr is so
while the lateral flow the lateral flow
is useful for picking up
um infections quickly and it's
convenient
and there's lots of positives to it but
if you do have any of those
either the key symptoms the cough the um
uh um fever and so on or unless
loss of senses taste or smell or if you
feel
you know really quite unwell and you
have a runny nose or a sore throat i
would definitely recommend people at
this point to go for a pcr test
either you can either get one sent to
your home or you can go to one of our
testing sites
and we've got good access to testing in
trafford
i would very i think at this point er on
the side of caution
and go and get that test done because we
are seeing quite fast spread in some in
in some settings
i'll leave helen to talk about the
contact well we've got contact tracing
on the agenda and i think
i think like you yes testing and
vaccination take you so far but unless
we're actually doing that contact racing
effectively
um we won't uh we won't make the
progress the difficulty we have
however is once rates go above a certain
level
it's you can't keep up with the contact
tracing from if you like
a an organizational point of view we
really become more and more reliant on
people doing the right thing and knowing
what that right thing is
because once you know on tuesday last
week for example
we had 84 people test positive in one
day
now you know most of those people will
have gone through the national system
will have filled in the forms correctly
and so on
but even if 20 of them don't that's
quite a lot of phone calls
conversations quite often you know our
contact tracers are absolutely fantastic
at getting that engagement having those
conversations with people
but we all know that actually people do
this better themselves
and we we've had one case which i'm sure
helen
will talk about but um a case where one
person
felt ill and was tested on a sunday
evening they put it on their whatsapp
group
by the following morning we had 18
positive cases
just because the person had taken that
action
and that meant those 18 people all
self-isolated straight away
and that will have made a massive
difference to the spread
so it's really really powerful what what
people can do themselves
but as you say making sure that we you
know in our community engagement work a
big focus of that is on the the contact
racing and the self-isolation
thanks helen um i've got a question from
khan khan
yeah um thank you chair
first of all you are asking whether you
want you want support for this
scheme i think we we are
from our community we are very
supportive of the of the scheme itself
and the action being taken by the
officers is really
command commanded but i've got three or
four small points
if i may one is i think the advice for
extended family is very very valuable
as you know you know in small houses
you've got extended families it's very
difficult
to isolate self-isolate uh so any advice
really is very reassuring to
to the families uh we also support the
setting up of these vaccine champions um
from our organization we are looking at
uh members of our community
who can come forward as we call them
ambassadors but
you know they're the they're the
champions
um my concern the little concern is the
role
of on the engagement of the army
um are we really wanting to see
soldiers on our streets uh i think that
that causes a lot of confusion amongst
many people
uh because of the uh news
internationally where
the army has gone in to support even
uh civilian authorities and that hasn't
been very successful uh so really it is
a
uh how do how do how will people feel
if they see soldiers with guns on the on
the streets
we um yeah no absolutely not we are not
having soldiers with guns on the streets
for this
if we ask for military aid it will be
potentially for if we were given
additional vaccines so that we could do
more vaccination
centers so we might in that situation
have military support with running that
vaccination center
so we had that we have military support
in january
and into february at the town hall
supporting us with the
um testing program when we were setting
up the initial testing program at the
town hall
they were really lovely they um
they there were no guns um they stayed
at the town hall it was very clear what
their remit was
and there was absolutely no we are
absolutely not
um asking the military to do anything um
other than if for example we suddenly
got a whole load of vaccines
then we might well ask the military to
support us
by um supporting that a
you know pop-up clinic somewhere so that
they would run that
um and it would not be um i mean
they do tend to be in uniform but
there's definitely no guns
they're extremely polite and helpful i'm
quite comfortable i come from a military
family myself so i'm quite happy with
that
but there's some concern with as you
you'll understand from
some quarters and there there will be
some activists who actually campaign
against
the armed forces coming in but anyway
that's that's reassuring
yeah i i think we won't get the
additional vaccine so i think
it's um i think it's a it's a slightly
moot point but we would absolutely you
know they are not
they are not here in a way in a military
role they're here in a
civilian support role um if if they come
in
but as we're unlikely to get the
additional vaccines i think i think it
won't be an issue but we're certainly
not having anyone walking the streets
yeah my final point is really the
engagement of the
communities is very very useful very
good
and people who actually participated
have appreciated the
the extra drive to engage the
communities to get vaccinations
thank you so much thank you khan um
dude councillor lloyd did you want to
come in at all your hand up
judith
no i think she's frozen uh i'll bring in
helen then helen you've got your hand up
helen collins
hi yes thank you chair um i'll cover all
the contact tracing items in the contact
tracing agenda item but
i just wanted to um assure um
members that what we do do when we know
that there is a confirmed case in the
setting
we do advise for anyone who feels unwell
to go and have a test a pcr test we
don't
specify it has to be one of the three
symptoms and that's really important at
the moment in terms of where we're
seeing the spread
so we are advising that but we're also
working incredibly closely with phe
both at a greater manchester and
national level around the change in
symptoms so as soon as there is any
change in guidance around who we test
that will come into our local team
really quickly and we'll change our
processes against that
thank you thank you helen um are there
any further questions
on the on can i
yes dave sorry go on transfer yeah but
it does disappear after i did i did see
it's actually dave i do apologize all of
us
and
i think eleanor you did say
17 to 20 year olds are the
largest group who have contacted uh
covet um what what age groups
are going into being admitted to the
hospitals
so i think it's crossed the age range
but um quite a lot for people in their
30s
again we've got quite high rates in that
group and of course that population is
unlikely to have had both vaccines
um at the moment it does seem like we're
hoping that hospital stays will
be shorter and the people aren't as
seriously ill but
it certainly is something where we are
seeing an increase in admissions and and
we just do not want to have
that happen the other issue with the
hospital admissions is that
of course the um hospital at the moment
the hospitals are now trying to
do all of the work that they didn't do
last year so the hospitals are under a
lot of pressure
so when people talk about oh you know
it's it's not so serious or
you know the rates of hospital admission
aren't answered as great as previously
well last year we
only managed by stopping almost
everything else that could be stopped in
the health service
and we really don't want to have another
summer of that we do need to make sure
that the
hospitals can run effectively so i think
longer term there's a question for us
about
making sure that our hospitals and our
primary care and community services
have sufficient capacity for um
you know for managing contingencies and
so on we've been running our hospital
and health services and social care
services at
with such tight margins that there
really hasn't been any wriggle room
um and it is i think something for us to
think about as a nation
about how do we two things how do we
make sure that we have a little bit of
capacity
in our systems whether it's in the
general practice systems or in the
hospitals and community services
so that if something untoward happens
we've got we've got space to
absorb it and the second thing i think
we need to be thinking about
is that we you know this inequalities
agenda that we we've um
seen again and again that we knew about
before covered
but it's so marked now and so what are
we going to do to make sure that our
population is healthier
going forward so that we have a less
susceptible population
in particular things like some of the
you know the risk factors that relate to
obesity
we are one of the fastest countries in
the world
66 of our adult population is overweight
or obese
and it's very hard to lose weight when
you gain weight
so one of the things we need to do is
work out how we can help our population
not to
not gain weight as we get older but also
looking at things even from childhood
onwards because obviously children who
are overweight
do um very are very much more likely to
end up overweight as adults with all the
health risks that gives
and so i think there is a big piece of
work for us as a community to think
about how do we make sure that our
population is as healthy as it possibly
can be
so that we can um so to reduce the risk
of covid but everything else as well
cancer
cardiovascular disease and all the other
things that
are actually more likely ultimately to
kill us
in terms of our communication obviously
uh young younger people are contacting
no it significantly and
uh you know if 17 to 20
um you know how are we looking to
sort of use our comms
significantly to that age group whether
it be six
forms or colleges and things like that
and universities
because we do need to get them to
understand
that you know it doesn't bypass them
and if you do get it you know this long
covered which you know
people who i know have experienced it
and
you know you don't know how long that
can actually last for
um and it is very difficult so
um how do we do that and the other
the just final point that i had uh in
terms of
businesses and how we sort of
um you know target them to make sure
that we are
um you know doing the right things in in
social distancing and all of that within
workplaces um do we go into trafford
park
because obviously there's a lot of
businesses in trafford park
and yeah so it's just so yeah so i'll
ask ellie to talk about the comms but
one of the groups we're specifically
wanting to make sure we get
good comms for is people in their late
teens and in their 20s
um and the other group on the traffic
park and the business engagement i think
a lot of that
we're doing some work sort of
preventative work with those settings
and but also helen and the team she
works with
and the environmental health officers
both have done a lot of preventative
work but also a lot of engagement once
there's an outbreak
so ellie are you able to talk a little
bit about the um
the comms and then helen on the um
business engagement
yeah so um i think obviously as we look
at the rates and the ages that they're
in we're looking at how we
um target those people specifically and
their conversations at the moment about
how do we engage
with education settings to understand
from them
um what sort of risk factors are so for
example
um all the research is showing that as
the vaccination gets offered
younger and younger people are taking
apps there aren't the barriers to
vaccination with young people that we
thought we might have
so we need to understand is it sort of
more risky behaviors
um is it a lack of testing and actually
you may not be able to influence their
behavior very much but um you know could
they be
incentivized to take up testing more you
know that's something we could do
through the um education settings
the other thing is um with all the work
that ben described is
engaging with the hospitality um sector
much more
and so a lot of that is sort of helping
businesses
to um help us with um you know anybody
who is
out and about um which is obviously more
likely to be
the younger ages who aren't to get
vaccinated and then obviously
um monitoring the rates and as we can do
on a daily basis
is we can target our con so obviously we
can actually spend additional money
to ensure that um our communication is
where
um i will talk audiences so for example
um digital advertising bands this week
the target is more
um lower vaccine uptake and then at
schools so
probably the late teens early 20s
probably younger than our sort of
parental age
but then you know if the rates continue
to be bad in that age group then we
could go to where they are
so and their sort of ongoing
conversations but they're just a few of
the things that we're looking at
thank you thank you ellie um
before i bring helen in i've got a
question from councillor lloyd
[Music]
to ask this question is uh counseling
which was but it does um worry me a
little bit because
um that's been reported recently
um ellen they said that
and what we should do about myself would
be using the piece eddie electrical
test because they're easy to get to
and things like that
and i think
a great job really on circumstances
and particularly and absolutely
infections
uh did anyone get the full gist of that
question at all
not just the normal ones so about the
pcr test well at the moment i think um
you know ideally go for the pcr if it's
um
you know we but if if you are starting
to have that bad headache
and a sore throat and a runny nose i
think at the moment it probably is worth
going for a pcr test
if you're concerned rather than just
relying on the lateral flow
particularly and we are asking anybody
who's a contact go for pcr testing
so it the other thing is if you do a
lateral flow test and it comes back
um negative but you still have symptoms
that
that could be covered we would really
ask you to
think seriously about going to have um
that
have that pcr test
thank you uh uh julian for that
councillor
uh linda blackburn good question
thank you i just wanted to ask um has
there been any evidence
with regard to people attending weddings
has has there been any evidence to um to
say that
you know wedding guests are perhaps
spreading
any any of the virus around so i think
as rates go up any mass gathering
particularly in indoor gathering adds
risk because you only need one person
who's positive there
and they could be you know they could be
asymptomatic or they could be in the pre
in the infectious phase but before the
symptoms show
so we are we've definitely through the
previous waves of the pandemic we've
seen um
linked to gyms we've seen outbreaks
linked to church attendance we've seen
outbreaks linked to
all sorts of social gatherings so there
will be
outbreaks that are linked to weddings
because and and
you know we've seen outbreaks linked to
hospitality venues
um so it is that thing about you don't
really know who's
who's infected and somebody could be
positive without knowing it
and inadvertently spread spread disease
so
i think with any of with any of these
events it really is about making sure
that it feel that it is safe and it
feels safe
so it's about trying to even at a
wedding trying to limit that
or or a funeral and it's so difficult
isn't it either
sometimes in a way particularly at a
funeral um
not to be wanting to give a hug to
to people who are bereaved and so on um
so
but it is that that really you do have
to be very conscious that at the moment
you you might actually have it yourself
or somebody else might have it there so
do be very very careful at any event
and do try and keep that that two meter
distancing and ideally
as much of anything that can be outdoors
the better because we we
do know that being outdoors really is
much much safer
thank you eleanor um i don't see any
further questions on this session but
before we move on
i think we i really must mention uh the
splendid work that early claudic has
done
on on the plan and the booklet
my only question i have now is how are
we going to distribute the booklets to
households and to businesses
so nigel or ellie yeah thank you
um councillor freeman um so
through a range of ways um the
environmental health
um team are being really helpful with
this so obviously they're doing
engagement with businesses
and i think hospitality this week and
then retail
and another sector next week so anybody
can
remember um and they've got the
um resources for businesses but then
they're also giving businesses the
resources for the public so
hopefully you know if you start to go
into pubs or um
they you might find them on shop
counters whereas again that's just the
booklet with the really basic testing
self-isolation vaccine advice
so we're hoping the businesses will be
able to help us with that
um nigel's team um will then
generally be using these so there's also
um the good news is that
there's a guide called the 10 ways to do
your 10 days
so the support for people to
self-isolate and
greater manchester have just kindly
translated that into ten different
languages
so nigel's team are just having a review
of those and seeing which ones of those
and would be particularly useful with
our engagement and then again with the
supervised um in-school testing that ben
talked about and nigel's team again will
be there and that will be an opportunity
to distribute um those materials to
people who they engage with
thank you ellie can i just make one
suggestion in terms of
getting messages out to businesses have
we thought about
uh employing our parking services
wardens who walk down centers
to just drop off into each business
uh a leaflet
i'm not aware of that something that's
been discussed um
laura is leading the business work but
i'll certainly um suggest it to you
thank you
i mean clearly that's a resource we
could use well
whilst they're still doing the job that
they're doing because you know you see
them in cell town center you see them in
olmsted
uh you see them in ultra gum and they
really could be just
taking a leaflet and doing if they just
did one male for you
it's a set of business that have been
covered but if you could take that
forward i'd be grateful thank you
um right we'll move on then to
um the item seven and uh first a
is mass testing can i invite helen
collins please thank you
i think that might be me on on yeah i'm
glad
i was thinking is it you thank you
cheers
no worries um so this is actually a
really kind of quick update because i'm
i think a lot of the
um kind of updates we've given
previously um in terms of you know
the vast amount of testing um that we've
done um
just kind of give a summary of it though
um in total we've done
1267 additional tests recently through
all that additional code work and this
week that number is going to
more than double um and that's not even
taking into account
the electrical flow test that we've
handed out so it has been a really kind
of massive effort from the testing team
the community engagement team
in terms of all that additional work
we've done as a result those rates rise
um so otherwise i think it's just around
kind of making sure that we continue to
promote those key messages
if you have symptoms absolutely go and
get um a pcr test
um if you don't continue to take those
two logical flow tests every week
and that's even more crucial if you
don't work in hospitality
um regular testing can prevent the need
to close down a business
because the site gets too many cases so
it's you know at the moment it's so so
crucial
for for businesses and hospitality
settings to make sure their staff are
testing twice a week and then the final
kind of big thing
that we were trying to emphasize at the
moment is that you don't need to really
test if you've tested positive in the
past 90 days
obviously what we don't want is people
having to go and self-isolate when they
don't need to be
um so just to kind of really really
emphasize that that message at the
moment
yeah just just a short one for me given
given the update i gave before on the on
the ten point plan
thank you ben any questions at all
anyone
i don't see any at all uh we'll move on
then uh
contact tracing and outbreak management
that is you helen isn't it
thank you it is i feel i can speak to
you about this
thank you chair so um i just wanted to
read your counselors that there's a huge
amount of activity going on with contact
trace and we're we're really engaged
um with our gm colleagues and locally as
well
so just to explain we have an outbreak
outbreak management and contact tracing
hub in trafford
which is myself kate and a number of
other colleagues who work incredibly
closely
with ben's testing team with our
regulatory services colleagues
education uh greater manchester hub and
public health england as well so it's a
really
really tight system that we're running
there's three levels of contact tracing
so level one a level three
is the national contact tracing service
that you'll know about
level two um is the ones where the
national system
haven't hasn't been able to get hold of
the confirmed cases and they come
through to our team in trafford
so we then have a team that's led by
tricia and max
miss kelly trisha jones who look at the
the different
um cases that are coming through and
allocate them to contact traces
at the moment what we're doing with our
level two contact traces which is
different than level three
is they're having a much more in-depth
conversation with people when they
manage to get hold of them
so asking a few extra questions about
where they've been
who they've been with and that's kind of
come from the delta variant
um issue that we've seen so really
in-depth contact tracing
aspects there and then there's level
three and that's a complex
outbreak management and contact tracing
so that's our
schools businesses care homes early
years settings all of
all of those really and and we run what
what we call outbreak control team
meetings around the complex settings
so um just to also say in terms of the
data so we get the
the level two cases that come through
and we get notified from gm
if there's a level one so a complex
setting but what we also have and our um
hub manager kate murdock is fabulous
with all things data
we have data flows so we have
coincidence data flows so this comes
from all across greater manchester and
nationally
of coincidences so where people have
been and that allows us to really target
our um
reactive work so at the moment we're
working with a number of large
businesses
and a very large um retail
setting um that we'll all be very
familiar with
um because you know there's a lot of
coincidences coming through there
the other thing that leads us in terms
of how we do our reactive work is common
exposures as well so we've seen for
example
um a large outbreak linked to a um
screening of a um football final
possibly
and that then allows us to really dig
into the date and identify all the cases
linked to that and work with the
community in the setting really really
quickly
so that's where we get a lot of the data
from um
we work as a a team obviously so we have
the hub team as the core team
but our regulatory services particularly
lee susan
and um nicola are fabulous in terms of
engaging
with the business in terms of the
regulatory side but we also have laura
strong who works with us
who does that triaging so she'll speak
to the businesses straight away as soon
as we know that they've got a case
understand the situation with them and
then we can get in there as soon as we
possibly can
our education team which is led by karen
samples john nish and jane
help us work really really closely and
quickly with our schools
and um so that's kind of our our
arrangement locally so it is
i would say it's a really strong and
robust offer that we have around contact
tracing
in terms of numbers we've worked with
over 50 complex settings
since september and if you imagine the
time that it takes to understand an
outbreak and work alongside some
companies
some are brilliant others are more
challenging
and so i think eleanor and i are going
to write a book on our experiences with
them
some settings uh we've had over 1100
notifications from our early years in
education
system so we've worked with you know on
behalf of those kind of cases
our level two so our contact interviews
that we have to do that come from
national we've done nearly three
thousand of those
so you can just see that the um the
demand that is coming through
but the other thing i think that's
really important to know is although we
do
talk through things in the pub as kind
of specific sections
there's a very chicken and egg situation
so the concept traces we work incredibly
closely with testing because as soon as
we see an outbreak we
work with ben around testing ben will do
some his team will do some additional
testing and then that obviously feeds
back through to contact tracing
so that's where we are so ben's talked
about some of the testing but this week
we have been busy the last
i would say the last three weeks we've
really seen an increase businesses are
busy we're working
with um i don't know how to describe it
a building with
more than one business in it at the
moment so we are working alongside 10
different businesses within that setting
um three of which have got outbreaks so
we're just trying to um
manage that but obviously it's it's what
it's looking really good and our systems
are really strong
we're working again with the large
retail sector and we're doing
three business engagement meetings this
week with them to really get
our retail uh leads involved in
um ensuring that contact racing is
robust
uh within their setting and they know
who we are and how to kind of
engage with both their shoppers and
their staff as well
schools we have activity across schools
at the moment
um and we what we also do is we run
fortnightly forums for all our head
teachers we've got really high
engagement lots of our head teachers
join us
and we talk about um we share the
information with them and then they come
back and tell us
what they're experiencing on the ground
and that allows us to change our policy
locally as well
so we are both i would say the outbreak
management hub and contact tracing hub
that
i'm working alongside our other streams
of work is both reactive
obviously picking up the cases but we're
doing a huge amount of proactive work as
well
so thanks thank you for that telling
it's
very very clear from what you said
there's some fantastic teamwork that is
going on
and it has gone on for a very long time
irrespective of the current situation
and and you know it really does show the
value of
environmental health of public health
and
and all the teams and represents all
working together um
to try and combat this pandemic uh any
questions at all
at all for helen
i don't see any so we'll move on to mass
vaccination invite rebecca to speak
please thank you rebecca
um thank you chair um i'm aware that
colleagues will talk about some of the
um
excellent community engagement work that
has taken place
over the past um a few weeks um in terms
of the vaccination program so i'll focus
on the kind of numbers
and key headlines today and take any
questions if that's okay
so key messages as of today so across
trafford
um over 75 of all eligible patients have
now been vaccinated at least once
um in terms of eligibility this week
and as of monday um those age 25 and
over could
um attend for a vaccine as per the jcvi
guidance
that changed yesterday to um 23 and over
and today to 21 and over and as eleanor
mentioned we are expecting that to be
all
um over 18 adults probably um by
tomorrow which is really good news in
terms of the
um obviously issues that have been
discussed and
as ellie briefly mentioned as well we
are seeing um a lot
of uptake in the younger population that
was something that we were
slightly concerned about in terms of
hesitancy but we are seeing um
significant demand in terms of supply of
the vaccine
and we have received our schedule
through until the end of the month
and we are getting um supplies into the
primary care network sites of both
astrazeneca and pfizer
and the community pharmacy sites are
receiving fisa astrazeneca and moderna
as well so we've got um supply coming
into the system which is great
we've also done a stock take of the um
the vaccines that we've actually got on
sites now that haven't yet been
administered
so that if we do um suddenly get a
request to do some surge vaccination or
open that up even more
we do have um stock on site not too much
obviously because we've been delivering
the vaccine but we do have both pfizer
and astrazeneca available um if required
which is really good we are seeing
some slight hesitancy in terms of the
estrogenic vaccine and not just in the
younger age groups but across
all age groups even those who um have
had their first dose astrazeneca vaccine
without any
um side effects there is some hesitancy
in terms of second
doses and so we are doing some comms at
the moment through jamie oliver and
ellie and the public health team to just
outline um the kind of the risk in
relation to the estrogenic
vaccine is much more smaller than the
risk obviously in terms of
um the covered virus there are some
national
leaflets as well that are available at
all sites
um in terms where we're up to with um
delivery sites so i think i mentioned
last time that
a couple of our primary care networks
have withdrawn from the wider programme
and that is just due to the wider
pressure on primary care and the fact
that there is a backlog of patients
there is the
increasing demand so we have two
pharmacies who are covering the west of
the borough
and one in amsterdam and one in
partington and
for the sale network um which has been
delivered from the live
center by the um by the sale practices
they
do their last clinic on friday of this
week but we have the
timperley pharmacy who's been delivering
out of the light kill centre
who has got that contract who continue
to deliver from the live
center for the wider sale population and
that will start on monday
so for people there will be a really
smooth transition it's the same venue
they'll receive the vaccine but it'll
just be a different provider so that's
gone um really well which is good
and the only other thing to know i
suppose in terms of headlines and where
we're up to and you may have seen on the
news this morning the discussion around
whether
the vaccination will become mandatory
for care home staff particularly and
potentially health and social care staff
and that isn't formal guidance at the
moment however through um
diane eaton and working with colleagues
in public health we are going to do some
further
focused work on some of our bigger homes
where we have got a lower than average
take up
from staff and again having people on
site to talk through the risks
and having the uh the jeep the link gp
to those care homes
available to deliver vaccinations so
we're going to get em on the front foot
really
and pending any guidance that comes out
so i'll
pause there thank you uh
counselor accordingly you had your hand
up do you have a question
um so it was answered but i've got a new
one
far away on on um
we talk about care homes um
but what about home care um
there's a lot of stuff that go into many
homes in a day
are they going to be included in this
you include you mentioned that
health and social care i just i haven't
seen any mention of home carers
and by that i mean the support workers
that go from home to home
i should yeah so those staff
were included in the first cohort in
terms of health and social care staff so
they were all offered
um the vaccine um very early on
um in terms of rollout and we're
absolutely part of that cohort of staff
what i haven't got is the um the numbers
in terms of home care staff i think it's
a little more difficult because
obviously they're not
all necessarily trafford registered
patients they might be out of borough so
it's quite difficult to keep
a track from the data that we have as a
ccg in terms of home care staff but i
can
assure you that those staff were
absolutely included as a priority number
one
thanks for that and and then the thing i
did want to make clear
uh earlier was that the um
the gratitude that um certainly old
trafford community primary
owes to uh public health they've been
really brilliant in supporting that
school
which isn't being a high um area
and yet we've many we've got through
this pretty well so far
touch wood in terms of um sending
bubbles home and what have you so we've
had tremendous support and it has been
effective it's been productive as well
thank you mike for those very helpful
comments um
i don't see any further questions at all
so
thank you rebecca thank you chad i need
to leave now apologies i've got a
meeting at 11 so i'm slightly late so
thank you that is fine thank you for
hanging on
thank you okay you too bae uh so we'll
move on to
community engagement and invite nigel to
address us
thank you chair so uh yes i'll give a
quick update on the community engagement
activity
since the last two weeks that the key
thing i probably wanted to update on was
the um
school listening uh community listening
exercise that we did and the door
knocking exercise so
if you remember we did some uh
a listening exercise which we carried
out with parents and guardians outside
the seymour community primary school
in may and what we did uh following that
was
we did a similar listening exercise at
king's row primary on the 28th of may
similar similar way to before pick up
and drop off times and capturing
residents covered concerns and attitudes
to an experience of the vaccination and
testing
program the team also offered guidance
reinforcing messaging around testing
vaccination covertake behaviors and also
gave information around the
isolation support that was available and
at the same time we were also working
with ben's team
in terms of supporting the pop-up
clinics at king's road and seymour
primary as well on the same day so we
spoke to
over 200 people at the school and
completed 80 questionnaires
and uh we asked the general question
around the kind of impact and how people
were feeling about covid where
10 being a you know significant impact
and
one being low impact and people were
around about six they're kind of
in the middle uh in terms of how worried
they were around covet
and in terms of the kind of some of the
feedback we got and we're still doing
some analysis on this but i just want to
highlight some of the some of the key
things that we found
with it generally uh there was low
vaccine hesitancy so that was really
good and the vast majority of people
that
we spoke to have been have been
vaccinated or or would be getting
vaccinated as soon as they were
given that offer the new variants were
causing
concern to people but generally
people were happy with the support that
they were had from the council
although they were some fears that
people may not all be self-isolating and
this was causing them some concern
and um in terms of self-isolation
there was you know a common issue in
terms of people feeling concerned around
lack of pay and the need to work if they
were needing to self-isolate so that was
some of the kind of key things that were
coming through
and then uh the following week we did uh
this door-to-door activity over two days
on the second and third of june in the
clifford area of old trafford so
similar engagement activity in terms of
capturing residents concerns experiences
and offering support and guidance
we were also handing out the pcr self
test kits
to people to support the enhanced
community case finding work
so we visited 842 households over those
two days
of which uh 356 people answered the door
and we spoke
to them and we completed 217
questionnaires and in terms of that
where people were on that spectrum from
1 to 10
kind of very much in the middle probably
just over five in terms of how worried
they were around covid
so we did hand out over around about 776
test kits
to those households that we spoke to um
but kind of much lower return in terms
of the score work
but i think around 93 test kits were
returned on those pcr test kits
in terms of finding some of the key
things we found again
we found which was encouraging that
there was low vaccine hesitancy and the
majority of speakers of
people we spoke to had had the first
dose of vaccine
although uh as uh rebecca mentioned
before there were just some concerns
raised around the az
vaccine people have traveled in order to
get to the vaccine
for example go to the yeti hat but also
a lot of people have mentioned the local
site such as the limelight center
seymour park and delamir
in terms of testing we saw mostly in
terms of people using natural flow tests
it was people
that had school children who were key
workers who were using natural flow
tests
in terms of the self-isolation support
available there was generally quite low
awareness
of that so we were promoting that in the
conversations that we had
and where people were having to
self-isolate they were very much relying
on
family friends and their social network
so that was kind of some of the insight
that we gained um and in terms of the
kind of two approaches that we did
the door knocking versus the score work
i think
everyone felt that the school engagement
work um
was more effective just in terms it was
less resources needed in terms of staff
numbers and time
it was more scalable in the amount of
work that we could do
more tests were submitted higher return
rate the
engagement rates were better and also
more feedback was gathered so
on the whole that seems like a more
efficient and effective way of working
although the door knocking work is
something we can still
consider and it's good for having
perhaps more in-depth conversations
where residents perhaps have a little
bit more time
um but yeah the personnel and the
coordination needing for that
door locking work is very significant
and definitely needs a lot more um
resources so in terms of other activity
uh some of this has really been covered
by ben when he gave the overview of the
ten point plan
but we're very much continuing with the
messaging through the usual community
networks and channels that we've been
doing for
uh several months now we're planning on
doing some more engagement work
at primary schools because that seemed
to be a very effective
approach so over the next five to six
weeks
and we're also looking at uh potentially
a poster competition with the year sixes
at primary schools
focusing on self-isolation guidance
beyond the primary schools closing
we are starting to plan now what the
engagement work might look like over the
summer holidays
while the schools are closed because we
really want to focus on continuing with
that family
engagement we're also going to be
supporting colleagues in regulatory
services with
the messaging and advice that they're
getting out and those
information leaflets which ellie
highlighted so um
i know that colleagues are going to be
supporting next week with visits to the
hospitality sector and retail sectors in
some of the town centres next week
and just one thing to mention we're
potentially also getting some support
from the cabinet office their street
team for one day so that's not been
confirmed yet but
we might have them available for one day
either at the end of june or early july
so
we're waiting for confirmation on that
in terms of vaccination clinics the team
are currently continuing to support the
clinics particularly the limelight
clinic in old trafford but also
coordinating the volunteer offer
and as has been mentioned already we now
have our volunteering officer in who is
something called claire mcguire so
she joined us uh just the last week but
once she's up and running that'll really
really help us in helping to coordinate
that
wider volunteer offer and just one thing
i just wanted to just mention at the end
was around the community champion scheme
this has now been launched we've got our
first champion signed up and we're going
to be having the first sessions with
those
in terms of giving them um their sort of
check-ins and q and a sessions with the
public health team
but we really want to just encourage as
many people as possible to sign up as
community champions as they
you know will be able to help share
messaging champion you know testing
self-isolation and vaccination
you know in their communities so more
details on the website of how people
can sign up and the other thing just to
mention
is the quarterly report which uh the
team have produced for the work they've
done over the last three months so i
know this has been shared by council
freeman
too to all councillors and
we're going to promote this as well
through a press release
which is going to go out shortly and we
want to also through that help
hopefully push the the message that
around promoting community champions and
that opportunity for the public to join
in with that work
uh that's it in terms of update for me
council freeman
thank you uh nigel um a very very
thorough
update and i do i i just will mention
the uh
the community uh engagement team quarter
four report update
i think it was an excellent way of
demonstrating how hard
we have been working in the in the
previous three months irrespective of
what's happening now
you know this clear evidence there how
how hard we've worked as a borough
to to combat this pandemic and and and
don't anyone else say any different
and it must be quite down heartening for
some some of you i think
when you see that the way it's presented
i think to us that
well why has this happened whose fault
is it and it's you know i know
when you've worked as hard as you have
um and and so
you know i'm very pleased to be able to
say that was circulating to counters and
i'm pleased it's going to be more widely
circulated because there's clear
evidence there we haven't sat back as a
as a borough we've been working very
very hard to combat this pandemic and
the circumstances have just overtaken us
and um
nobody's to blame for that at all um
is there any questions at all for for
nigel
no um the next item on the agenda was
community enforcement unfortunately
just um sorry councillor freeman just
before we move on to that
um i was wondering kirsty johnson's now
here so i wonder if she could give a
very brief update on the pathfinder work
the self-isolation because that ties in
probably
quite neatly with both the gender items
yes please over to you kirsty and
welcome
hi thank you i'm kirsty i'm one of the
project managers working on the
corvid 19 response particularly around
outbreak management
across gm and we've initiated
a pathfinder so it's across all gm local
authorities
um any in trafford and
the pathfinder is going to be running
for 12 weeks and what we're doing is
proactively contacting people to offer
them self-isolation support
and so predominantly it's going to be in
m15 and
m16 postcode areas and with the
potential to expand that to
other geographic locations based on
what's happening in those areas and it's
kind of to identify any barriers to
self-isolation
and make sure that people are isolating
so
at the minute they just get asked a
national question by the national team
on do you have you know would you like
any support while self-isolating
and often the answer to that is no
um so this is more of a proactive
engagement and contacting
them um to explicitly state what kind of
support we have on offering trafford
and then working really really closely
with our partners
to track that journey a bit of
handholding to make sure that they're
getting that support
and so we've got some comms going out on
the back of that as well
obviously we already have the twitter
feeds on 10 ways to do your 10 days
and the community engagement team uh
distributing booklets in those
geographic locations
and we're going to be tagging things
onto the end of school letters when they
get in isolation
around a self-isolation booklet and just
so people know
what support is out there when they're
self-isolating
thank you curse there any questions at
all from anyone
i don't see any thanks very much chris
it's very very useful
well we'll move on then to community
enforcement and report fortunately helen
grant has center apologies but i do have
an update from her
um the update is as follows that the
enforcement group the meetings have been
reduced to fortnightly
there is still an operational group
within community safety licensing and
environmental health and gmp
resident complaints are now few and far
between
and environmental health continue to
carry out visits and to advise
businesses uh anything else you want to
add to eleanor to that
no just just how very powerful and
useful that group is i mean obviously we
try to use enforcement as a last resort
but knowing that that enforcement is an
option
does um does sometimes can be very very
helpful to us
um in in encouraging people to engage
but enforcement as i say remains the
last resort
thank you i've got a question from
council accordingly council accordingly
just switched things on yeah um
it's all it's more general in a sense
it's um
i've got a concern that there is
a minority of people that are really
suffering
um mental health issues through
uh this and um
it's a sad fact it's a sad metric
but it's almost a daily occurrence in
greater manchester
that there's a motorway suicide it's
becoming
an issue um you know and we are seeing
um as a counselor i'm seeing more and
more of this expression the other side
of it
is um young people or
or young adults really um
behaving in
a lack of sort of um self-preservation
um so racing in traffic park is a
i'm not seeing organized racing but i am
seeing an
awful lot of ridiculous speed suddenly
almost drag racing along barton dot road
as a solo person and
it worries me slightly
that we need to pick up on this because
it's moved away from sort of group
disobedience to almost
um desperation individual desperation i
think
and maybe the the situation is evolving
now rather than the need for
sort of police enforcement on groups
i'm just wondering if that's
everybody's perception or is just mine
really
so i think the mental health impact of
covid is massive and
it it's playing out in all sorts of
different ways and i think one of the
things we know from any
any sort of um uh
crisis or or um serious incidents
and you know it's particularly something
that's as long playing as covid is that
the mental health impact
is often lower to begin with but then
increases over time and stays stay
significantly
high even after the incident is closed
um so and obviously we're nowhere near
closing
covet as an incident at the moment so i
think the mental health impact we we've
certainly working very closely with our
mental health services they report
having people you know the the severity
of people
presenting with mental health issues has
has massively increased
that's both from people who have
pre-existing conditions which have been
made worse through the pandemic
or people who are presenting for the
first time
we know that as well with some of our
young people that um
being out of school is no good for them
at all and we really do want to try and
make sure that children are able to be
kept in school and young people are kept
in school as much as possible
um the impact of people being sent home
to isolate at that age
is massive the home schooling impact has
been
been huge and um obviously for parents
who are trying to work
at the same time and and you know
there's definitely
um there will i think as we look through
the data we'll definitely see that
that gendered issue of some of this
falling more heavily on women
than on on men particularly around
parenting
we also know um you know we've had
serious concerns all the way through
around domestic abuse
and um in a locked down the ability of
people to be able to get away from
domestic abuse
and are we able to make sure that people
are safe in some of these settings
so you know on and um and and i i know
that
our um youth violence uh support team
have seen some very very nasty incidents
recently and and you know have some
serious concerns about some of this so
it's a massive issue i think it's one
that we are going to need to return to i
don't know whether it's something that
we want perhaps
um i mean today we talked a lot at the
board about our response around the
um enhanced response plan but i wonder
whether the
the mental health aspects of the
pandemic is something we'd like to bring
to the for a discussion at the pebb one
time
and have a a um you know use
use the peb to think about the mental
health and
improve how we improve mental people's
mental health i think one of the other
issues is of course we still have
it's reducing but we still have some
people who've been extremely anxious
and even though they've now had double
vaccines they're still really concerned
about
coming back into normal life and are
very concerned about
the risks that are opposed out there um
so
i think there's there's some real issues
for us uh both about
over anxiety and under anxiety and about
all the mental health impacts
of this plus of course
we know that when things like in spring
you know we do see that sometimes
people's mental health gets worse
because
things are not getting better for them
but they see things getting better for
other people and i think we can expect
some of that some issues relating to
that as well
as we emerge from from our various
restrictions
that for some people their lives won't
feel better
once those freedoms are reinstated for
them and it's how we support people
through that
as well i i think this is going to be
one of the longest impacts that we have
from this and one of the things we need
to be thinking about
most carefully about how we plan and how
we support people going forward i'd
certainly welcome
was returning to this um i think it is a
big
my sense as a counselor is it's a
growing issue
and it's on very sort of quirky metrics
but it's there
yeah i agree thank you uh mike
for raising that and would certainly
could bring it back i think
the mental health issues is very much a
multi-agency approach as well
and i can report that when i was on the
police and crime panel last year there
was a report
presented by greater manchester police
to show the effects of mental health on
through the pandemic um in normal times
97 of people presenting to them with
mental health issues were known to them
and this is substantially dropped to
into the 70 percent
during this pandemic so that i think it
makes the point there you've made the
point there mike and it's something we
can return to
but perhaps we need to also scope out
who who additionally we want to attend
the
the peb and maybe have a paper
circulated in advance which we can all
consider
and comment on is that okay mike
thank you um can i um is there any other
business at all today
i don't see can i just thank you all for
your attendance and your patience with
the meeting it's been rather long term
we've nearly used it all the time
um we continue to be in quite a
difficult situation i'd argue
in relation to the pandemic it's
certainly not going to go away it's not
gone away
and i'd just like to reiterate
again my thanks to the work that
all our staff all our volunteers all our
voluntary sectors are doing right across
this borough
this clear evidence we're working
extremely hard and
let's hope that by the time we meet in
two weeks time
that our rates will have started to come
down
thank you very much for your attendance
and your patience this morning
thank